yogic just wants his horses he wants to
go home he's tired and his biggest worry
right now is that he won't get home in
time for Sunday for his horse race
because of this little thing called the
championship parade Stan you need to get
this man to play we've known that yoga
just a massive horse guy I mean he
accepted his 2022 MVP trophy in front of
his horse stable in Serbia and when
someone asked him what he was going to
get Michael Jordan for his birthday he
literally responded with nothing but
horse he treats basketball like we all
treat our nine to five just work and
then when you're done with your work day
all you want to do is just get the hell
home to things you truly care about like
horses he literally said nobody likes
his uh his job or maybe they do they're
lying